you wrote a th000 words a day for 600
days in a row yeah what the
well first a th000 words is not
that much yeah it's not that much but
it's it feels like feels like a lot I
mean it compound like on one hand so a
th000 words a day is probably two and a
half pages right and I remember Tim
feris talking about this Chris Gilbo
talked about it the way Chris Gilbo
phrased it he had this like it's really
easy to write a book every year write 50
blog posts and another 50 guest posts a
couple long form writing projects maybe
some magazine articles he like just
lists out all the stuff he's like it's
really easy to do that in a single year
everyone's like what takes years to
write a book it takes years to do all
this he's like if you just write a th000
words a day and we talk about like
habits compounding over time and you
know these small things adding up but
600,000 words is an insane amount of
content